okay so this is a drill
to help with your attention get your
understandings okay
so you're
still doing inward spirals
this is one
this get on
is an outward spiral it's an hour's move
it's going this way this way
it starts
and then goes that way
it's not going like this
this way
here
clear boom
this will make no sense with the knife
so
spiral now you're going to have that
weak grip grip grip you say you're out
here
you're going to have to peel like this
this one is
aggressive
this way
we're going to add a clear but once it
gets weak hold it in place
this
so to do this my elbow is going to come
my elbow comes to the center line
do you see it's on the underside
don't leave your elbow out like this
it's sweet push
this is coming in
center boom this way
here now here's his disarm right there
boom
my elbow comes underneath
this way
and then there's your cross lateral
check on this this elbow here okay
so
and i don't want to turn it here
the elbow comes in
that is sweet
elbow underneath and in on your spine
don't shortchange it no
feel torque boom
okay
so when i bring the elbow in i don't
break it at this hinge
so you can watch if i just rotate the
arm that the elbow got closer to the
center line elbow got closer to the
center but it's not on the center line
center line's over here
so
as that's turning my right hip is
pushing that in and now it's on the
center
don't go and move it over
so my right hip is driving my right hip
is driving it
driving it
and you'll see as i go back
my right hip comes back out of it
right
not r
okay
i'm gonna use that movement here
you see my my hip is going to come
forward
torque everything
all the energy
boom this one
don't just do it casually
boom squeeze everything
[Music]
not back towards you
not back
through
this way
if you're okay and we have some luke
they can't have their stance attack
don't attack it
come wide
[Music]
here
but don't start going like this
this
boom
beginner
no displacement
okay again you're not trying to bend
someone backwards you're not trying to
bend him back that's not going to work
no one does that
you have to get used to only
accomplishing minor minor tilts minor
tilts that's all i need
the rest of it happens with the body
lock and the kazushi powder
okay
so that's why there's no reason to go
like this
you're not trying to get him to spin
around and you're going no no that
doesn't happen
minor body lock that was all i need
now his face is open
and now i lock his body with my body
and i displaced his base
so
that was all i needed right here
don't go no he's not bent over enough
all you need is that now his face is
open now this angle back here is open
in through his base
boom in body lock body law
this is the homo lateral body lock okay
with the outer spiral
is the homolauro body lock
with the inverse spiral
again
not this big banding
and then you come in
that was it he's in it i'm gonna hit the
body lock
that was it
i'll lock the body
and this of course if he's going fast
enough
forces can
create a body lock due to the inertia
he's going to he's so much of him is
going that way the inertia
will lock his body it can't happen but
in training
now
in training it's uchikomi you're going
to hit his hip with your hips boom
body
not here
not there
that's his body now
okay
so the body so this was the knife
movement right the knife's in my hand
so if my body attacks
here
this hand does not go back
his hand goes down
down
don't try to push him don't try to make
him go into the painting that you are
imagining so don't take the end of the
technique don't this is painting the
antenna i'm going backwards
you're not throwing backwards
you're spinning his body
moving
so we're going to do just that half okay
and again we want some conditioning so
i'm going to tank on
and that hand is going to go here oh
you do this rod
you're going to go to your outward
outside
[Music]
jacked up
so we're not going up we're just
focusing on the bottom part okay
okay so now you have to resist your
temptation
don't make it go by don't make it go
back you you make it go back then you
start doing the the inward spiral you
start doing the inward spot you're
winding up to go back
oh
not like this
boom
much